[موسيقى]
انا مجلس الامن اللي هو لازم ينظر نظره حل
المشكله
في اساسا هو مجلس الامن احنا لا تورطنا في
هذه المشكله
ومش قادر يطلع منك
ولازم يمنعه حتى في الانتخابات وبكره نحنا
نعمل الانتخابات
اي واحد يدخل الانتخابات
الرئاسي ولا انتخاب البرلماني يجب ان هو
يكتب
بالقبول بنتائج الانتخابات يا قرار عن
ميسي الوطني
[موسيقى]
يا تركي خاصه لان قبل 2011 غالبيه
والمركبات الجامعيه
والتعليميه والصحيه كانت متعاقد معها مع
شركات تركيه هذه كل شركات طلعت
والمشروعات خسرته حضرتك
هذه التنميه هتستوعب الجميع حتى تستوعب
العماله التونسيه هتستوعب العماله المصريه
حتستوعب العمال الجزائريه وبما في ذلك
اخوتنا الافارقه يجوز ليبي يشتغلوا فيها
يعني ليبيا بلد قاره
[موسيقى]